this is going to be a power packed video
we're talking about YouTube growth 101
how to grow if you have a small channel
so if you're just starting you're trying
to reach your first 1000 subscribers and
Beyond we're going to be getting into
some nuanced tactics many of which
you've probably never heard before and
we're going to be going through some
specific channels so we can look at real
world content that are from our
community talking about YouTube shorts
talking about Longs thumbnails titles so
buckle your seatbelt and today I am
welcomed
I am joined by my friend Rob from vid IQ
who is a YouTube expert Rob how's it
going hey Sean how's it going I am
currently having a two of ten day and
what that means is that I've launched a
video today that's a two of ten so I'm
fairly satisfied I'm not ecstatic but
I'm feeling good I think that we're tied
up uh Nolan dropped a video on think
media today it is two out of ten and I
also just heard that YouTube news
announced that they're debating on
removing that feature or allowing people
to turn it on or off because it causes
anxiety and I get it all right you're
like I gotta get a one out of ten I
gotta get and then you know you see 10
out of 10 and you get depressed you know
kind of Ben and Jerry's watch four
episodes of Netflix and then try to
sleep it off but um I'm excited because
we're gonna dive straight into uh Jesse
Frankel's Channel he's up in Toronto all
things real estate and immediately I'm
stricken struck by kind of cool
professionalism of the channel it does
feel like the thumbnails are clean
there's maybe some tweaks we can make
there so I'm going to let Rob make some
observations
um and this is he's a commercial real
estate broker and investor that's unique
um and he has also been a contributor to
the Bigger Pockets YouTube channel
we are not posting on the community tab
come on Jesse we'll talk about that in a
second we've got some shorts coming out
here and we've got some videos so Rob
what are some of your initial thoughts
so I would say that the channel from a
foundational point of view is set up for
Success I'm seeing a good structure here
love the channel Banner very
professional do you just scroll up again
um I just want to see they do have a
value proposition a relatively simple
one all things real estate and what it
seems to appear is that they're not
localizing themselves to a certain area
so they have I guess a broader reach
With Their audience
that's follow free with the thumbnails
as well Sean I think these are of a
particular strong order as well the one
thing I might think about and this is
just potentially an experiment
do you need to have two faces on the
thumbnails you have the host and you
have your guest
do you require the guest or the host
that would just be something to
experiment with because the more faces
you put on screen the more text you put
on screen and then along with the
backgrounds they are starting to get a
little cluttered and in some cases I I
like to call this like thumbnail
wallpaper uh they're using the same kind
of text on in the middle of a thumbnail
and from one thumbnail to the other I'm
seeing that the the host is the same
face over and over again on a lot of
these so perhaps adding a little bit of
variety but those are the initial
Impressions and I've also seeing one
breakout video here as well with 1 300
views the economy and commercial real
estate investing 2022 curious that here
the year was 2022 when that was
presumably published in 2023 was that
kind of like a review of last year I'm a
little puzzled by that title but the
format did work so you know could they
just republish the video
good old ads oh that's a great idea and
uh we're gonna flop over here to think
media so I have no ads we'll check out a
video here in just a second and to go a
little bit deeper on your strategy you
know exactly what we're doing today is
what she suggested uh you're obviously
uh our uh wise guest today but in terms
of positioning the content
um I did a thumbnail
um that is just solo me and it makes it
more simple allows the text to be maybe
more simple Etc and so we go back and
forth but that's a great point do you
need to quote unquote Force two people
into the thumbnail and you have the you
you have the option to do two people you
could do just you as the host you also
could do just the guess and thinking
through which of those would be most
strategic is a great question as we look
at YouTube this video this was two
months ago so it's right at the end that
is interesting it was right at the end
of 2022.
and so but yeah the economy and real
estate investing 2023 and update that's
a great title I think the other thing
that I notice here is most the content
or almost all of it is
30 minutes 41 24 39 a lot of what would
seem like a video podcast
which is great if you're setting
expectations for that but then the
question becomes what what could happen
if some clips came out of here or if you
did some growth based videos maybe this
is one of those that's a solo round
let's check it out I do a quick video
here I was lucky enough to be featured
on a podcast called CPI it's Canadian
passive investment setup as well good
lighting I like the studio setup yeah
and one thing immediately that hits me
though in this video is
I think the opening could be a lot
stronger you know hey I'm about to do a
quick video okay I was featured on a
podcast recently all right I was well
what what's like the takeaway or what's
a big hook or what's something that's
going to really grab me as to make me
want to stay around for seven minutes
let's see post is August and Ava awesome
team someone topical because we're
talking about the Canadian real estate
market uh I'm here in Toronto I think
originally they are um from out west
western Canada and we were talking about
some of the expensive markets and just
Capital raising in general so I'll play
that quick video uh yeah
we are 30 seconds into this and I as a
viewer I'm asking myself this is all
fascinating for you the Creator what's
in it for me what value are you going to
deliver to me and I need a kind of
reinforcement of that hook in the first
30 seconds and I think also the title
um was somewhat functional as opposed
goes to exciting as I understand it Sean
the video that you released uh on think
media today was with a title expert Jake
Thomas who has all of these awesome
formulas for making really curious and
clickable titles so Jesse I would highly
recommend watching that video we also
did a video ironically enough with Jake
Thomas that got released today as well
that's also talking about title funnels
like Jake Thomas has just appeared on
the scene has taken the title writing uh
World by storm good question for you
highly recommend checking out Jake
Thomas on think media and vidiq
100 and uh this is that video he's
talking about and I I think that's
another lever I think investing in the
hook
um and and powering up the title real
estate investing in Toronto and raising
Capital like it's kind of flat and
um I actually you know today's video is
brought to you by vid IQ uh we're
hanging out here with vid IQ I wonder if
we could fix this title here oh we're
using the vid IQ AI coach and uh real
estate investing in Toronto how to raise
Capital quickly okay okay it's getting
there so real estate investing in
Toronto or
well how would you tweak it
my question would be
almost trying to deliver a little bit of
fear or anxiety into it for example is
real estate investing in Toronto uh dead
or is it uh is 2023 the worst year to
invest in Toronto real estate like
something that adds a little bit of a
curiosity in a I don't want to set the
viewer in panic mode but you want to get
them asking the you know trying to get
the answer to the question
um all right so I'm gonna go write 10
titles for real estate investing in
Toronto and here it gives us some more
options real estate investing in Toronto
the essential guide the ins and out of
real estate and investing in Toronto now
I think we're in so we want to raise
capital
and so you could say write 10 titles for
real estate investing in Toronto
um and raising capital
and so
all right
Insider tips and and a lot I notice a
lot of these titles all kind of seem
kind of just bit the economy and
commercial real estate real estate
Outlook what makes the city Thrive I
think there's a lot there's a little bit
of an opportunity I think with topics
and type raising capital for real estate
investing in Toronto Secrets Revealed
then you eliminate the guests because
maybe no one's going to recognize the
guest in the thumbnail you do just the
host and the host has got a house with a
with a lock on it and light coming out
of it and like like it's locked up what
are the secrets inside of the house you
have you start thinking through and now
that would be how the title thumbnail
could play off each other unlock hey
unlock unlock powerful strategies to
raise capital for Toronto real estate
investing so this right here is just the
the vid IQ AI coach taking a title or a
topic you have throwing it in there and
then realizing how maybe it could allow
you to Pivot if the title is true
if it is about getting started or if it
is then you may be able you could go
back and improve some of your current
titles but especially for future titles
um that is an opportunity that you have
as well and by the way if you want to
check all this stuff out you can get a
30-day trial of vid iq's paid plan for
just one dollar at vidiq.com forward
slash think and you get access to this
and a lot of other cool stuff that we
can dive into a little bit later
um big shout out to vid IQ for
sponsoring today's video and uh by the
way we're gonna do some q a so if you
have a question put four question marks
before and after your question Rob and I
will be tackling those
um but any final thoughts uh for Jesse I
think there's a lot there titles
thumbnails uh topics and um get that
hook right in the videos I think what
they may be doing with their titles and
perhaps their content in general is
aiming solely full search
and while that can occasionally get you
some decent Evergreen content and
traffic
as you say Sean I think there's an
opportunity to make the titles just a
little more intriguing a little more
emotional and
getting the viewer to potentially feel
something before they click on the
videos right now I feel as if they're
very much search driven titles and in
2023 you need to be a little bit more
sophisticated than that
okay
always dropping bombs thank you Rob and
let's dive into the next channel for
today and that's seven sparrows Farm
let's see what we can learn here this is
an interesting new feature maybe it's
been here for a while but your about
page you used to have to go to about not
a lot of people probably really went
there we would often coach people that
the reason to write strong words and
copy on your about page was almost more
for you than it maybe somebody would go
there but it was that you would take the
time to articulate and get clear on the
vision of your channel but now right
below the name and the YouTube handle
and the subscribers and the amount of
videos is kind of a quick uh little
arrow that when you click it takes you
to the about page which also speaks to
the first sentence
um of your about page is now being seen
on the channel home page and on the
homepage you could click that it's going
to take you over here so you may not
need to even say welcome to seven
sparrows Farm because that's already the
title here
you may say something here like
you know animals farm structures
planting and tools and everything for
Farm enthusiasts or something like like
as concise as possible tagline that also
is Another Touch point that YouTube did
you you know how long this has been here
Rob
I think it's kind of appeared
sporadically in the last couple of
months so as you say it's very new and
what have you got to play with there
maybe 50 characters I'm thinking of
try to think of writing a title for your
Channel
in the sense that it's a value
proposition
very good so this is animals farm
structures planning tools and everything
in between 300 000 views on the channel
by the way shout back to Jesse use the
community tab shout out to seven
sparrows Farm five months ago they did
have a post but it's been a while it's
not gonna absolutely change the whole
game for you people say is the community
to have a secret well no it's not the
secret but I dished did a talk at Social
Media Marketing world uh one of my big
topics was was 11 different Insider
hacks and tips and tools like the
communities have we grew 1 500
subscribers just from Community tab
posts in the last 90 days on think media
now we already have momentum I
understand our channels whatever but
nevertheless just Community tab posts
have led to new subscribers so just
don't ignore the community tab would be
the tip of uh
the day there but uh we've been around
two years with 222 000 views on the best
way to split and stack firewood we may
be been around longer but that's the
most viewed video that I can find
um and still out here being consistent
and on the new uploads a day ago two
months ago so really it's been a couple
months since a new upload has happened
but five power tools you need for your
homestead here and as I dive into this
this gets me excited because
I
am
excited about affiliate marketing and
sure enough Amazon links are down here
for the Ryobi circular saw jigsaw the
impact driver good video topic for that
and show you some of the things that I
put together and check this hook out
today we are talking about five
must-have power tools for your homestead
now these are five different tools that
we've used in a lot of different ways
we're going to show you those I'm going
to give you one shows the tools
there we are there was a little bit
yeah so so rather than just talking head
what people want to see is the tools if
you have and right there you're kind of
hiding I know like it's a little bit of
mystery but but even if you actually
just clip all five tools could be
overlaid with b-roll while you're
talking in the intro is that how you do
it Rob I would say so like a two or
three seconds just hinting it
potentially what I do all like the the
quick thing that they do but it's so
fussy you don't quite capture it you've
got to carry on watching to find out
what they do and how how much they cost
and how you put them together
yeah I wouldn't be too afraid of like
spoiling it like oh now I get it it
actually just kind of in a way wets the
viewer's appetite to want to see more or
you show stuff like this a lot of Limbs
which is like oh I can do that I do need
to trim one of my trees you know you
start seeing kind of it in the wild and
you have great b-roll here so that'd be
a good way to power up the hook one of
my personal
preferences too is when doing chapters
and time codes is not using the word
intro it's actually just trying to say
something different than intro because
the reason why is viewers are becoming
so Savvy that they a lot of times will
be like I'm gonna skip right to power
tool number one because if you've
promised in the title five power tools
you need then I can just skip here and
say no you know I don't need you to tell
me what you're about to tell me I could
just give it right to it it's not to say
that there shouldn't be an intro
essentially a hook that's teeing up the
context but it actually has caused me to
rethink my openings that there'd be some
value in it or um a lot of times if I'm
doing maybe even a training that's kind
of YouTube based about Trends or
something I try to pack a stat right up
front or something like it you know new
data just came out that there's now the
YouTube podcast feature and I'll show
the article just to make the intro
actually something that's different than
just an intro you know so people don't
necessarily skip through but that's just
a little tactics so Rob what are some of
your thoughts about seven sparrows farm
so I just wanted to add about the
community tab absolutely you should be
using it as soon as you have access to
it and
we think
the aspects of the community tab are
overpowered specifically polls and a
brand new tool that's come up very
recently q a where you can ask a
question
and have somebody you know you got two
questions or four questions or four
answers and then you choose the right
one and you seem to get a lot of
Impressions from those posts and they're
very high degree of in um engagement we
sometimes get up to 30 to 50 engaging
with our community tab which is
incredible uh for the reach that they
have and it allows you to reach your
audience when you are not posting
content
uh so like you post say once a week you
could do six Community posts on the
other days to make sure that you're
still reaching your uh
viewers audience on a regular basis
as regards to the um
Channel we saw that there was one
outlier video wasn't there Sean that had
about 200 000 views and I also noticed
that it was two years old
as you often say success leaves Clues
make part twos or in this case remake
this video and you could make it in such
a way that it's shorter so the best way
to split and stack firewood in five
minutes can you condense this video a
little bit so it has a new angle to it
maybe you've learned something new in
the last two years or maybe you're just
a better content creator so it's better
production values and so on and so forth
because this is Evergreen content this
is one of your entry points into your
channel and I guess the other question I
would ask is have they added affiliate
links to the older performing video just
to make sure that the best performing
video is getting the same opportunities
so they've got the gear they use but
perhaps not what their
could potentially have an affiliate link
maybe some of this stuff maybe this much
higher dude heavier Duty thing could be
on Lowe's or Home Depot or some other uh
industrial type of site maybe they have
it affiliate link that's a great Point
um and what I also think spinning off of
that smart advice
is
turning it also into different content
formats success leaves Clues make part
twos you said shorter instead of eight
minutes maybe it's an it's a condensed
five minute or six minute version or
four minute but also a YouTube short yep
and a YouTube short that maybe has a
a voiceover because of especially when
you have b-roll like this you could show
you're like the three best ways to split
firewood or so because it's the best way
to split Sac firewood and you show this
tool you show them all
you show the other way or you just show
one way like this is a cool if you know
want to save time when splitting
firewood use a splitting ball so so if a
video has five points there's the short
version less than 60 seconds and maybe
just shows the b-roll really quickly
um and then if it could also just be the
one spin-off Point could be turned into
a YouTube short and when you are you
know in in our program called video
reggae Academy we start with reverse
engineer would be the first one and then
research but if you're thinking ahead
during your content creation process
you may be thinking I could do the less
than 60 second version of this because
I'm already getting all this footage I'm
already getting I already kind of had
the framework of it you know recently uh
I did a short about
are my favorite kind of vertical video
setup that I'll put off to the side when
I'm on a podcast so I can repurpose the
uh footage and I did it about it's a
Sony zv1 and we've done many videos this
could be a 10 minute video easily right
but it also could be a 44 second short
that just shows off the things so if you
have five tips some kind of listical
five things seven things you can just
quickly go through it and and maybe it
leaves people wanting more you then
would have the opportunity to do a PIN
to comment that links to maybe a longer
version or in this case I actually did a
pinned comment
you know citing that these are affiliate
links and put a list of the gear and I
actually give a call to action at the
end of the video that says check out a
list of the gear in the pin comment and
so just different things you could do
taking your winners and repurposing them
into other types of content Rob what do
you think about these thumbnails
I think they're of a generally high
quality these are some of the most
popular ones the latest ones are a
little more
I don't want to say amateur but that
some of them I think are trying to play
on a bit of humor like The these animals
holding power tools in the latest one
and then the chicken here with a hat and
they're feeling cold
sometimes I think creators can try to be
a little too clever
in their thumbnails and it loses the
essence of a messaging and that that can
be really tricky to do like you think
adding detail and more ideas for a
thumbnail makes it more clickable but
the truth is
a viewer or a potential viewer is going
to see your thumbnail for a second maybe
two seconds and they have to have that
instant connection with the thumbnail
and with this one
I'm trying to I'm I have to first work
out why the animals are carrying power
tools and then there's a question mark
there as well so without the title this
could be some kind of weird animated uh
animal fight going on uh but actually
it's about the best five power tools
but because these animals are in there
holding the power tools it kind of loses
a little bit of it instinctive immediate
recognition of what I'm getting to
getting into in the videos so maybe Sean
they might just be overthinking the
thumbnails a little bit too much in some
of these yeah I literally if the other
thing that's interesting is you
sometimes feel
it's five best power tools
and sometimes you feel like you have to
put all five in when really just a hero
shot of one tool or the most looking
tool that's also you said it exactly
right trying to be too clever it's clear
over clever if you confuse you lose and
people's attention spans are so short
our brain power is also so worn down
like we're just we're being accosted by
so many options of things to click on
and so many different advertisements so
what we want to do is do our best to
simplify messaging for viewers if it a
second to go what exactly is that we'll
move on even if I only do so
subconsciously just because of fear pure
fatigue whereas if we have clear
messaging that cuts through the noise
then someone goes oh that sounds
interesting and they click on it and I
would agree not only that but if you
think about the rule we call it the rule
of three we don't actually call it that
we stole that from Netflix and there was
a great article about Netflix thumbnails
that typically you're shooting for like
three things it could be a tool a
question mark in the background or it
could be a one word a tool and you
probably not an animal because the
animals wouldn't use the tools but all
that to say is if you do add these
things up we have one two three four
five six things happening here in the
thumbnail
we have quite a flat thumbnail as well
because the I think the background is in
sharp Focus so yeah your your eyes have
been drawn all over the thumbnail
this this Casey neistat there's Casey
it's over it's kind of two things in the
background super clean it works every
time the word the the graph shooting up
a couple logos that's three or four
elements three elements is kind of you
know different things we're after we're
doing similar things over there so I
mean the the takeaway is not trying to
even you want to find your own style
it's not that iq's style or think media
style but the Simplicity of the elements
the Simplicity of the messaging those
would be the universal principles that
all of us could use to uh strengthen
our
thumbnails and get a higher
click-through rate Joshua says is there
a tool that measures micro expressions
in the thumbnail image and Compares it
to what micro Expressions get people to
click the most so we all know the
YouTuber face if we're on the vid IQ
channel here
I am so frustrated and discouraged I am
happy I am almost mad and full of energy
I am fatigued and disappointed with my
Revenue I think that's what we're
talking about micro Expressions right
Josh do you know anything on this Rob I
spent uh an entire day doing I think 150
YouTube Expressions last week to get all
of those looks
um
I think generally
a very strong expression without it
looking ridiculous so what I do is when
I'm taking my thumbnails is I take three
pictures of myself so let's say we're
gonna do one which is shot first it will
be the normal one
then the slightly exaggerated one
and then the just ridiculous one
and I'll take
you know a a barometer of which one I
think is most appropriate for the
thumbnails I've got a bit of choice
there
seeing the whites of your eyes is
generally a good idea and also
um you don't necessarily have to look at
the viewer but if you're looking at an
object say the viewer is going to track
your eyes as to what you're looking at
in the um on the thumbnail as well
so those are my general bits of advice
for uh thumbnails another thing I also
do is we're trying to learn how to
sharpen our thumbnails so that when you
shrink down a thumbnail it loses an
incredible amount of detail so you
almost need to over detail the thumbnail
in order to keep some of it when it's
shrunk down and we're just experimenting
with it now we've just got our hands on
our thumbnail designer who knows how to
use Photoshop and they are doing some
really interesting incredible work with
it
yeah and Joshua I don't think we do know
of like a tool that is algorithmically
studied there are definitely a lot of
people who have data of of these days
stoic is kind of the trend actually
there's a lot of just you'll see stoic
faces
um I was looking at uh hope I think hope
Shoemaker is kind of uh it's kind of an
interesting example but it's like a
like a uh
they're still like an art form to the
stoic it's and and recently we shot
that's not who the person is I'm trying
to Hope scope is what it is so that's
what it is hopesco and uh unless it's
not it is okay good
um and so you kind of have
or her facial expression is kind of like
almost the same and it's not
um
super exaggerated in any One Direction
you got the hand on the face and so
recently we also kind of were going more
more stoic a slight uh the one cent yard
sale different different things we're
doing with the eyes obviously these are
kind of Photoshopped a lot of people
take cues from Beast uh who kind of has
almost an anime cartoon kind of yeah
overlay what is also interesting is you
look at because some people say well I'm
a professional
and if you look at someone like an Alex
tremozi whose channels blown up and my
friend Caleb ralston's his kind of
creative director and you just just
smiling uh the eyes AI stoic and
determined and so yeah I think it's
about finding your own style but yeah as
far as tools go Joshua I think
experimenting and doing all of the above
um going to take a couple quick
questions before we get into the next
Channel we're not doing open Channel
reviews these are just a few channels
from our video record Academy program
shout out to our sponsor today
fit IQ and definitely check links in the
description and resources including a
30-day trial of niq's played paid plan
for just one dollar lots of Cool Tools
in there like your daily ideas tool new
AI tools like the AI coach competitor
um tools that I love to use to get data
and insights from competitors Trends and
all the above
um and before the next Channel I want to
take a quick question
how do you convert long form videos to
shorts there's a couple different ways
to convert your long-form videos to
short form there is the remix feature
that would be the ability to just
actually take the YouTube video and
remix it but when we say convert videos
I think about actually editing shorts
intentionally into a new piece of
content which would start all the way
back at the beginning of your production
and maybe thinking through of creating
the shot a little bit wider because you
know that if it's framed this way that
it's going to really crop into my face
if we go like this but if I'm thoughtful
to maybe have the frame be a little bit
wider then actually now this could be
potentially a better short and if I use
Final Cut or Premiere or anything I
throw down my timeline
edit my video export it upload it to
YouTube and then maybe start a new
timeline in the vertical video format
take the b-roll from that I've shot on
the other one grab a USB mic and say
Here's five tools you should use uh farm
tools that are essential and do a
voiceover and just show the b-roll of
the tools and actually create a short
that maybe has a fresh hook if I've done
a script or some outline for my longer
form video I could probably quickly do a
40 second script voice over and then
just use the b-roll for my longer form
video or clips from it so I know I just
threw a lot at you but when we say
convert I don't necessarily just try to
mean like force an edited finalize
YouTube video into a short best practice
if you've got the time and the margin
and you plan this out into your workflow
is to use the assets that you already
have and make them into a dialed short
that can really potentially crush and
you might rework the hook and rework the
end and switch some things around
all right let's dive into the if you've
been getting value today hit the like
button we're going to jump into Valerie
Jim men's Channel look at the about um
on that one actually I love that lead
your life with power and purpose that's
a nice value proposition this year from
the description good call clean
um I my OCD if I have that is a little
bit
life it kind of feels like it's um title
case but like it's not
one of the things text wise that
frustrates me is like picking a style
and this is that is not gonna make or
break your channel but if you've ever
heard of title case converter.com one of
my favorite websites you could take this
you could put that in there and say
convert to title case and it's actually
going to be lead your life with like
it's funny that and is actually
lowercase but that's what title case
would be in in terms of the words that's
also the AP version there's other
versions of title case not the topic of
today and that's not gonna make the
results as your Shadow but just
something to note
um and so as I pulled this channel up
let's first get a vision so lead your
life with life and purpose my the
problem with that to me Rob is
I don't quite know what that is okay if
we go a little bit deeper it's true
dedicated if the channel is dedicated to
life it's a little broad learning also
kind of broad growing all right thriving
and loving
I I get the energy from the channel
however
and and I I think channels like this
could succeed but those sound
if I'm bold and just blunt kind of just
like nothing words like what did you
just say there you know it's just sort
of it's gonna grow Gonna Learn let's
Thrive we're gonna love like man I want
to do all those things but what exactly
are we doing and then as it goes deeper
it's actually I'm going to be sharing my
work with real estate investing so we
got super specific tips on how to start
your real estate investing Journey
and create generational wealth and so
I kind of thought we were going to go
more personal development more you know
maybe manifesting or just
learning personal development and then
we went to real estate investing so if
we head over to the content
we do have a transform your life
challenge that's happening
but then we also have where to buy my
first real estate investing property and
before the transform my life challenge
was a lot of was all real estate tips so
I'm a little bit confused Rob what are
your thoughts
so the thing that's really grinding my
gears here if you just scroll down uh to
show the thumbnails I'm gonna ask this
Creator a question
um for the transform your life challenge
did you make the videos before you made
the thumbnails and the titles
and my guess is that you made the videos
and you got so tired and exhausted
making the videos that you had zero
energy left
to make a clickable thumbnail and an
intriguing title
and unfortunately the last thing you did
is the first thing that every single
potential viewer sees
from your videos and
they feel like they've been phoned in
and that's really going to cost you uh
views here and I think we can already
start to see like these ones where to
put a bit more time into relive it and
real estate investing and they have a
specific Niche there The View counts
where I think 50 or above and this
transform your life challenge I'm
already starting to see the views start
to to drop a little bit
what's in it for the viewer like
transform your life challenge day two
what part of your life are you going to
look at
for me personally
um Sean I will be trying to think about
how these videos can stand on their own
feet two feet without
episodic titles and thumbnails like what
is the specific goal of this day is it
to become uh better at your morning
routine or is it to become better at
going to sleep at the right time so that
you wake up the morning fresh and
energized or is it to make sure that no
matter how busy you are you eat
breakfast really dial down on one of
those goals and achievements you want to
succeed in for that day
if you want to carry on on this
transform your life challenge but then
as as we already identified from a
channel perspective it seems to have
been a huge pivot here from one
direction to the other
great insights uh let's let's listen a
little bit here to day two and see what
we learned guys day two of our 21 day
transform your life challenge
what do you want so for what it's we're
going through layers of coaching here I
like
what do you want even more than day two
because think about hook first and then
like welcome back to the challenge like
and then potentially even a better hook
like
you know when yeah but let's see what do
you want in life in business in your
relationships in this present moment
what do you want to have now it seems
like a very open-ended question and I
understand that can be one other thing
that just kind of I was noticing from a
production level the audio is pretty
good but where your mic placement is is
not really the ideal placement for a lav
mic like that yeah
um the hair maybe is rubbing on it on a
little bit a little bit I I think the
final result is still a good service to
the viewer because it's certainly
Audible and it's probably much more
clear than if it was just the on-camera
mic overwhelming so let's break it down
so in your Journal write down the
question and so to Rob's point though we
have the opportunity here of maybe like
tips for journaling or tips for getting
Clarity in your life or how to go from
confused to clear in your life you want
or what do I want in first person for
yourself
and then ask how to get a Clear Vision
for your life how to get clear for work
for business what do you want do you
want to open up a business how to set
goals how to and to that point then
during the transformation transform your
life Channel you front load a powerful
title each day now respect to the batch
production same sweatshirt so I'm
assuming you may maybe you shot all 21
days
um you still have the opportunity though
to do unique thumbnails and unique
titles that are are superior as this
challenge evolves
um and and as you put it into a playlist
or whatever I think to go back and to
think about the structure of it just to
get more return on investment out of
what you've already created to the point
of
the power and purpose show with Val or
or whatever's happening there
I think that all of the above is great
you're you're leading Real Estate
Investors do need to set goals there is
a mindset piece to it Etc
um but there that would be that thought
on that challenge and I would agree with
Rob as well when you kind of lean in on
this other content with real estate it's
a little bit more clear and if we talk a
little bit about thumbnails in general I
think
um cropping in a little bit more a lot
of times we don't need
uh you know waste thumbnails are so
small it's fine but like you can you can
come up so much closer to the camera in
terms of how the shot composition of you
is and then when possible I think
there's we have a little bit too many
words and that is my opinion I know
there's other opinions that you don't
really need like the show I see
eventually you removed it you don't need
your show name or your branding on the
thumbnail I think the person who does it
the best is Evan Carmichael I don't know
if people even understand it but it's
just a little paper airplane that's
always in the corner and he also has
similar color schemes but power and
purpose
in the per like So eventually removed it
but I would remove that you don't need
the Subscribe button
you probably don't need the little micro
the glass because it's small enough and
you don't need to Echo the title in the
thumbnail it already says five myths of
real estate investing debunked so what
you really could say is biggest myths or
you could say real estate myths or you
could just say myths and there's a logo
of a house and if they're myths your
expression could also be maybe more tied
into that but overall your ability to
create thumbnails pulling out these
stock footage question marks your
ability to your photography of yourself
um you've got so much raw material here
to I think make some tweaks to this
channel to to really help where it goes
next I think the big question is what is
going to be your branding what is going
to be your messaging what where do you
want this to really go and I would point
you to as a as a VRA member as well
inside of your members area is our Niche
Finder course which goes a lot deeper
than just getting clear on your topic
but it goes into like branding
positioning the big picture uh if you
haven't watched that I highly recommend
watching that Val any final thoughts Rob
unfortunately the way the YouTube
platform works is that it's not
structured to funnel uh viewers into the
first video
of a series
like the um Challenge Series that
they've started so you have to
understand that a viewer could start the
journey on your channel of day 28
um and it's you know if you're gonna set
up a course on skillshare or udemy then
fine the structure is there but
YouTube is a
an interesting Discovery
um
swimming pool and somebody May dive in
today 25 of your challenges so that uh
going back to
um the the three thumbnails that you
have here let's think about how each of
those videos can stand on its own two
feet and as you said um
Sean if it's not too late try and bring
the hook of those challenges to the
Forefront and then once you've got the
viewer engaged then you can explain
maybe why you're doing the challenge
um but I mean it was funny how you went
through the um the thumbnail a little a
lower down the miss one it was like
everything you're doing wrong with the
thumbnail and do the exact opposite and
that's like as if you can make the
complete opposite of that thumbnail it
would be a one of ten you know your
click through rate would be through the
roof
um and one other thought here is back on
just branding is I think that
we all go through this with empathy oh I
don't know if we all do I know that 99
of us too and I did as well it's kind of
like you you yourself I can tell are
into personal development you've got
influence on the you got the 10x rule
you've got like maybe Rich Dad Poor Dad
and you've got these books over here and
so you probably know as a real estate
investor that mindset and all that stuff
is what helped you and then you do have
the very clear real estate investing
videos but under this power and purpose
brand in March just last week you posted
a video that's like embrace your inner
child I'm guessing this is you know your
child or maybe a nephew or something
like that but nevertheless the context
of even this very video
and they allow themselves to feel is is
you expressing maybe your art and vision
but what is what does that have to you
know okay your body is your vehicle to
make this life your Masterpiece so
believe that you are the type of person
to have a consistent workout routine to
eat healthy and so
I I I guess what I'm trying to say is I
feel you you're crushing it business is
hard entrepreneurship is hard overcoming
bad news and people you know shutting
you down four tips to support you on
your wealth and wellness journey and
maybe you're also sharing some of these
over on reels and you have the ability
to repurpose them here but I am looking
for a little bit of cohesion and just
the brand and where we're going I think
this makes Incredible sense to me four
tips to help you on your wealth and
wellness Journey but then if we go
hardcore real estate investing at times
remember you never want to upload videos
subscribers didn't subscribe for so if
you're kind of more of a if it is
workout mindset read then then that's
why I really want to point you to Niche
Finder I think it's one of the most
valuable things we've ever put out at
think media just because Clarity is King
Clarity is power and it really can help
you cut through the noise it seems to me
it seems like if this is kind of a funny
analogy Rob but I like to if you're
watching this
sounds it's going to be awkward but if
somebody squeezes you what comes out
[Laughter]
but like you know if you squeeze 11 11
juice comes out if you squeeze in orange
orange juice comes out if you're trying
to figure out what your channel is about
some people took it to a weird place uh
you know I think it sounds like if you
squeeze Val what are we talking about if
you squeeze thou I think like wealth and
and habits you know and and kind of
inspiration that's kind of what comes
out and maybe your career is yes real
estate investing it might even be
eventually that there should be two
different channels however I highly I
would not recommend trying to do both at
the start until there's systems or
editors or people even helping you if
ever but like
if somebody squeezes you you're watching
this what comes out and and a lot of
times we maybe have more clarity about
what our channel should be about than we
think we do when you go to a bookstore
what section are you gravitationally
pulled towards you can't you have to go
to history you have to go to self-help
personal development you have to go to
psychology you have to go to the
children's books you go to the magazines
and you go to the design books and the
things that you keep if you find
yourself drifting from the brand of the
channel you thought you should start
and drifting back to like the things you
really want to talk about well maybe the
things you really want to talk about is
because you're an orange and you should
be producing orange juice but you felt
like you know professionally it makes
more sense to do real estate investing
or whatever so anyways for what it's
worth I hope that uh that analogy helps
you uh I'm certainly going to ask that
question on our community tab straight
after this live stream I just wanted to
add it does feel as if we uh picked out
a lot of things that Creator was doing
wrong but there was also some green
shoes they've got 50 subscribers I
noticed that some of their shorts had
over 1 000 views some of their real
estate videos had over 100 views so
there's all there's a lot of positivity
there some creators you know in their
first 10 videos don't even get more than
50 views so we I do want to end you know
just ensure that there is good stuff
going on there but like
because we've done Channel lotus in the
past John we're always like loads of
focus on what's wrong what needs
improving and we sometimes need to take
a step back and say this crit is at the
very beginning of their Journey they are
doing some things right and there's a
lot of things that we suggested there
and I would suggest just of all the
things you've just written down the 27
improvements that you need to make on
your channel tackle one of them per
video and within three months your
videos will be unrecognizable to what
they are today
and there's a lot of wisdom I mean
literally the stream yard HR department
uh has entered the chat and I am uh I
can be vulnerable right now not only
that Circle H scuba dropped a lot of
wisdom yeah you should not squeeze other
people unless you have a formal
relationship with them and there's
consent uh you shouldn't squeeze people
without kid said but ultimately there
are some insights that if if you squeeze
an orange and orange juice we're gonna
leave it Rob I don't know if we went
there was it good we did it's too late
there's no turning back and this is live
stream as well and Victoria is exactly
right uh
moving on
um all right let's hit some uh cues here
and we'll drop some A's does the
community tab show up to those who are
not even subscribed I'm not sure how it
is open increased your subscribers Rob
that's what makes it incredibly powerful
it reaches beyond your subscribers and
every time you post there is a subscribe
button that's big clear and there to
click on and because it's on the home
feed it is a different visual cue to all
of those videos that have been also
played so when you post on your
community tab
in my opinion never post a video post an
image post a poll post a question post
an animated gif something that's going
to catch their attention and as um Sean
said the think media channel is getting
a thousand subscribers just from what
five minutes work every single day super
powerful tool but you've got to be
patient with it as with all things on
YouTube it's not just gonna immediately
start giving you lots of Impressions and
an engagement you've got to do it for
three to six months to start seeing some
results
the next question is do you think it's
possible to become a big commentary
Channel or content reactions Channel
still Sean
um I do I think that especially in our
VRA Community you know we're seeing
people all the time start new channels
in crowded niches and break out I think
trying to figure out how can you be
different trying to find out a unique
angle on
um something that is it seems like
everybody is doing when you're not
trying to beat the best it's different
is better than better and another
resource I'd recommend that we haven't
really talked a lot about I'm going to
do some podcast episodes on it is
positioning there's a book called
positioning
and this book is pretty wild because
it's uh
It Was Written in 1980s the second 20th
anniversary edition was written
in 2001 and what they described in this
book was that
there's over saturation in the market
there's too much noise and we are an
over communicated Society
it was 2001. YouTube didn't exist
Instagram didn't exist the internet had
barely taken off and they were saying
the secret to standing out in an over
communicated Society is positioning and
positioning is probably not what you
think it is and this book breaks that
down and so as you can see it's marked
up at a pretty crazy level and I got
this whole thing it's like a this thing
is like a a battle plan it is a it's it
is a good book and that would be the key
is it still possible to become a big
commentary Channel well of course the
intersection of mastering all the skills
on YouTube that's why I hope you're
subscribed and you know watch trainings
like this titles thumbnails topics
you're on camera presence and all those
kind of things but even saying that one
of the most fascinating points of this
book is is it even talks about companies
and it talks about that even Talent is
it the difference that might sound funny
that having even the best people
at a company using that analogy is not
the secret literally you're positioning
if you have the best people and all the
money in the world but you actually
attack the wrong you try to dislodge
Coca-Cola it's not happening Coke is the
number one Cola brand Pepsi has never
been able to dislodge them the key is
not to try to become Coke the key is to
figure out how to be a niche beverage
and start ollipop and have fiber in your
thing and be a to start hop water which
is you know zero calories zero alcohol
and start something entirely new right
now a lot of hop seltzers and Waters is
a blowing up category it's not competing
with anything else different is better
than better and so we'll link uh we'll
link that up I think that positioning is
a great read and resource that uh could
help everybody watching this stand out
in a 2023 world it was it was it's scary
relevant for 2021 and it's more relevant
today than ever in 20 in 2001 okay
and 20 years after that it's more
relevant than ever before lost curious
does it hurt a Channel or content to
post long form shorts live streams on
the same day
and I currently upload six to seven days
a week Rob what would your content
Cadence be I think first of all it very
much depends on your audience for
example if you are appealing to a gamer
community and maybe they're under the
age of 80. probably got more time on
their hands and they consume a lot of
content and they consume shots
however let's say you're appealing to a
busy
um business minded person who has a
family of three and most of the time has
taken up looking at their children and
their business they can probably only
stomach one or two videos from you a
week and they're very quickly going to
get overwhelmed by the content you're
pushing out in our experience
it doesn't matter how many shots we seem
to post it doesn't seem to have an
impact on our alarm form content in
actual fact the more shots we post the
more views we seem to get on our long
form content but baby that's just
anecdotal experience from our Channel
and the live streams are a strange Beast
really you need to be identifying the
best time to go live for your audience
uh because the
reach of that live stream typically
speaking tapers off very very quickly
after the end of a live stream uh very
much like our channel on let's do the
same thing we get a big community in the
live stream but then uh the audience is
waiting for the next live stream as
opposed to watching the previous one
love to hear your thoughts on this one
Sean considering uh you have two
channels operating two or three channels
you do shorts you do long fun content
you're publishing I know you're
publishing five videos a week and like
was it two shots of the weekend but
you've kind of mixed things up how's
your experience of multiple content a
day gone
yeah these days we're kind of mixing it
up we're also trying to figure out our
theme this year is built to last what's
a sustainable Pace we're we're focused
on breaking out and resting this year
different people on Mars I'm gonna be
taking a break and all this stuff which
all is is probably a separate topic
that's him you were recently rob you
were moving you're on a break I think
that that is a strong topic for creators
in general because there is a level of
fatigue and when you're publishing a lot
of content and even at think media with
the team but when I could speak
specifically to this question that we've
learned is I don't hesitate at all to
upload a short on the same day as a long
sure it's like yeah that's like two
entirely different maybe try to space
them out but even if they're not super
spaced out that doesn't really bother me
we also will consistently do live
streams on on the same day as a normal
upload as well mainly because recently
the new YouTube podcast feature is very
fascinating and so uh it was more of a
quick turn a lot of times a live stream
for me might be a reaction to something
that's happening in the news and so a
video came out schedule upload at like 5
a.m our local time and then I'm going
live at 11 or one and so I don't
hesitate to do that as well for the
average person though I would space it
out like one of the things we're doing
is if we don't have a long to upload we
upload a short on the think media
podcast Channel this very Channel every
day we don't upload a long we upload a
short because we just have a a lot of
vertical video that's kind of being
produced so I don't know if that's a
clear answer I just I actually probably
wouldn't worry about it too much but I
would maybe space it out
rather than force it on the same day if
if you have seven total I would probably
upload them at seven you know a short
one day live one day a long one day
um and and if you are we're we're a
media company obviously with multiple
creators therefore
um you know I I'm not worried we're
oftentimes we're doing more than seven
in a week if you add up lives videos and
shorts yeah and so not too uh stressed
out about it I'm excited about this
question because our answers could be
different Jay says what is the number
one analytic you monitor
I'm gonna answer and then Rob's gonna
answer
and and actually no what we're gonna do
is we're gonna count down three two one
I'm gonna say it at the same time you
only get to say one thing Rob oh okay
and we're gonna say it not on one
basically on zero I'm not going to say
zero three two one views views
um so it's funny you say because because
the truth is if I'm studying our
analytics I am going to study
click-through rate average view duration
avpv we're gonna dig into traffic
sources and all this other stuff but I
think my reasoning and I'm curious your
reasoning is because of this right here
I mean top content in the last 28 days
it is giving us average view duration of
it but at the end of the day views is is
how these are structured and ranked and
so yeah side of think media I know I'm
spinning off on the question
I I am aware that your lower viewed
video could have driven more clients or
leads to your business or a lower viewed
video could have brought more depth to
your community or a lower view video
could have driven more affiliate uh
actual sales and generated more income
but when all things are said and done we
did the countdown views is the one thing
that we measure Rob what's your thinking
on that why is that I guess I say views
to counter argue argue subscribers
because the the last analytic you should
be paying any attention to once you've
got a thousand subscribers to monetize
your content uh subscribers and Sean if
you could share your screen again for a
second and maybe I've just been
influenced by
um this tool that we've had at vid IQ
for years at this point it's the views
per hour on the channel so right now I
can see that and think media is getting
9 000 views per hour and I've followed
the analytic for the vid IQ channel for
years
because that's kind of like the resting
heartbeat or the Cadence of the channel
you know we used to get a thousand views
per hour then we start to get 2 000
views per hour then 4 000 views per hour
and there's that gradually grows what
we're understanding is that not only is
our new content performing better but
our Evergreen content is performing
better and if that continues to go up
into the right over a long period of
time then your channel is growing and
then as you say Sean you can drill down
into analytics such as return viewers
Impressions watch time but ultimately
although shorts has kind of
um messed up this analytic a little bit
views
[Music]
as long as they're continuing to climb
your channel is in a healthy state
if you're getting value in the Stream
hit like we have a couple more questions
and one more channel that we're going to
be learning from today which is the
um and so the gaming mom gaming for
parents and their Gamers so audience
is parents is mostly online digital
business using YouTube to educate
parents on gaming and Technology
we have 6134 views
videos 10 negatives to video games how
to have a chill Friday with bear and
breakfast
live stream very long live stream wow
five hours okay so is this playthrough
okay
some kind of a game here
which is uh Jan explores bears and
breakfast live on Twitch
okay so that's the maybe the game bears
and breakfast Early Access
trap a warning for gamers have you ever
heard of Early Access games they are
games that are available to purchase in
an unfinished state with the promise of
further development and updates it's a
great way for game and we're a v tuber
here
on in terms of our content we got some
b-roll we have the frame around here
developers to meet certain standards or
provide guarantees about future updates
and fixes
this means that Gamers have to okay and
so uh Rob what are some of your thoughts
for the gaming mom so what I find
interesting is first of all presumably
they were streaming on Twitch and then
they brought that recording of the
twitch stream onto YouTube and then
uploaded it as a video on demand
yeah because it doesn't say was life
because it doesn't say it was live I'm
wondering how successful that is for
um
the Creator versus their twitch stream
I'm really curious as to what they were
doing with the thumbnail if you just
won't go to latest again um Sean they
had a thumbnail which was
completely different to everything
they've done in the past it's almost as
if they may have used like a canva
template and tried to experiment with
something new and different
again I'm not sure how well that works
versus The Branding on the rest of the
channel
and then we have this interesting vtuber
style which
was visually interesting
for like I would say 30 seconds and then
once I get used to this new style of
presenting I wasn't seeing any b-roll or
any graphics appearing on screen so it
was if the Creator put all of their
efforts into this v-tubing experience
without realizing that unfortunately
viewers still have a very short
attention span and they're gonna get
familiar with this view quite quickly
and then want to see something
interesting and different and other than
this text appearing on screen
how visual engaging is this for the
viewers so I know I've picked up again a
lot of potential challenges for the
Creator but that's what I was noticing
from first impressions
yeah and that's an interesting thought
um if we are going into the vtuber world
just like you would want to switch
angles in a physical on-camera scenario
if you had multiple angles or different
shots or different pans if that was
creatable a zoomed out shot that showed
the office the office you know the
Virtual Office or whatever that
theoretically could be more interesting
and or
the the vtuber character is there to
your point 10 or 20 of the time but just
like any other video it's a majority
b-roll or a majority gameplay keeping it
kind of interesting there I also would
say
I I do think that we have a a niche
Focus challenge because
to your point
you know live on Twitch and gaming the
parent who's trying to keep their gamer
safe or be educated about gaming is just
probably not going to care about your
gameplay yeah yeah I would agree with
that and so
you certainly you can with the size of
the channel and where you are now you
can take it any direction I would argue
because there's probably there's not
like momentum that would would hurt you
the gaming mom is a really cool brand
and it's kind of like I think it has
potential but this is also kind of a
Niche Finder type of a question
that is
I would imagine there are some
you know tips for parents of Gamers I
don't know I wonder if that's like a
niche is it really possible to build a
brand around that I was thinking of a
search term parental control video games
and seeing what came up there there's
probably going to be some how to's from
uh potentially games companies or like
from Sony or Microsoft and how to turn
these things on I mean wow 45 million
views there I mean healthy gamer like
what are they trying to do over here I
spent
dating advice
I tried intermittent fasting for
technology
kind of interesting but success leaves
Clues this would be a good channel to to
maybe research a little bit if that
hasn't hit your radar what I would think
is that a lot of these would be a
one-off video as opposed to an entire
brand as my guest healthy gamer it could
be the one to
you know Dr Phil covering video game
addiction
and so that that becomes one of our
biggest questions is like the viability
and the total addressable market and
also the fact that a one-off video
helping a parent it's gonna be way
different than building a brand and
having them subscribe and wanting to
come back especially having them wanting
to come back to watch you play bear and
breakfast or whatever but what I also
think is interesting is if you were to
go more towards gameplay reviews any
word that's happened to
essentially the gaming mom where my
brain goes
is
you could look up the data I would guess
mother aged
women
who play
things like Farmville I think we're
talking Millions
umville wow that's a plus from a past
and that might not be the hot game right
now Rob see I'm not obviously in the
cool mom game culture
but like Farmville 2023 tips
you know and Farmville three
I'm on this now we're now okay so we're
in Farmville 3 level up game play
um and so
that that's like literally building a
community like moms who love to game
and there'd probably be a certain type
of games now that's just that would be
an angle it could potentially go and
then in addition to that it would also
you would not be forcing people to be a
part of your community you may just
share
um you know three how to level up in
Farmville three and that attracts some
certain levels of viewers but your brand
your channel name becomes clear and then
there's maybe like a group of you know
moms who also love to game and they
maybe maybe there are some ethics that
you're playing wholesome games or
something like that you're playing a
certain type of games and tapping into a
niche there so to me that goes back and
we talked about even positioning it's
like picking out the niche the
positioning the thinking behind the
channel any final thoughts on this one
uh if you can just bring up the channel
again uh Sean go to the most popular if
this Creator wanted to stay on the topic
of
um protecting
um your children from
the appropriate content on video games I
can see your most popular video is how
to set up parental controls on a
Nintendo switch so as a proof of concept
I would say right we've got the three
biggest consoles out right now which is
switch PlayStation 5 Xbox I would do
tutorials on how to set up the parental
controls for all of those devices
hopefully they've changed in the last
year uh so the switch one could probably
be updated then I would look at the 10
most popular video games that children
play so you're talking about fortnite
you're talking about Minecraft
WWE 2k wrestling etc etc FIFA and I
would be doing very simple tutorials on
the parental controls for all of the
most popular games very search based
um very
um
I guess one hit videos like you may get
a viewer interested in that video game
and then that returns your channel but
to find out whether or not there's a
sustainable
long-term viability for that type of
content on the channel as a proof of
concept now maybe you want to
intersperse it with all of your other
content so you do these these 10 videos
I'm suggesting over the next six months
interspersed with what else you have
um because as you say Sean I like the
idea of becoming more of a community
based Channel where it is gaming moms
who also have
um children who like to play video games
as well might be the idea
um and to your point if we stay on
Mission because she has a mission of
educating parents in the world of Gaming
if we stay on that and some of your
advice it makes me think about
um
it might it's it
some business models are kind of bigger
than YouTube
and
maybe blogs or articles or building a
personal brand or becoming a resource is
it's thinking about where is your
audience like it's it's where is your
audience where is your basically Target
Customer because your mission is to help
parents educate parents on the world of
gaming and related Tech and so the
YouTube channel can also be a resource
but potential chances are you're not
going to become a staple in a parent's
life you're going to become a touch
point when to your point that there's a
search based problem there's a problem
there's a particular thing and there's
it's enough of a mission but then on top
of that there's maybe other angles to it
the discipline though is realizing like
well how do I keep sustaining content
and there's some of these gameplay
videos that to me feel
like maybe less is more you know like
just focusing on topics
that are like that instead of let's
let's play stardew Valley and how is
that educating parents on you know and
then that your Twi your Twitch Channel
may be different than this particular
resource with this particular Mission
you do interviews with uh video podcast
you do interviews with experts on
psychology and gaming and you do news on
different reports that have come out on
gaming and whatnot that's like a
particular thing so uh really I hope
that's helpful and with all that
we are 12 minutes past the hour and we
do have a we have a customer successor
trade in Vegas today and my wife and I
are headed over to do some meeting with
our team in person who flow in so we
have to land the plane Rob people want
to check you out though
where are you at and what are you guys
up to so when I started uh working for
vid IQ I was melted down into my
constituent parts
and so I have no social presence other
than with vid IQ so whether it's on
Twitter Instagram mostly through the
channel uh you'll find me there helping
creators
essentially do what I did and that was
to turn my passion into a career and I
want to enable as many creators who have
that same dream to achieve that goal as
well but it looks as if Dan's doing all
of us especially head shorts
um and so yeah definitely head over to
vid IQ on YouTube and subscribe so much
valuable information over there Rob
thank you so much for jumping on today
and also big shout out to uh vid IQ
um in relation to sponsoring this video
super grateful and if you haven't got
your 30-day trial of it iq's paid plan
for just one dollar you could go to
vidiq.com forward slash think there's
also a link down in the description I
highly recommend you check out the
description by now uh Victoria's
probably dropped a link we mentioned
positioning today great resource um that
uh I think is is critical in 2023 if you
are a book person and into kind of stuff
like that and definitely also subscribe
because
we have uh this is the think media
podcast channel in fact we have a new
episode that we dropped this very week
all about how this channel got hacked
was down for 10 days and uh snubs uh
Shannon Morse uh came on who's an expert
that shared the most valuable stuff that
we've ever really I've ever heard in
regards to staying safe making sure your
YouTube channel doesn't get hacked and
so highly recommend uh checking that out
my name is Sean Cannell rhymes with
YouTube channel this is the think media
podcast Channel subscribe if you're not
subscribed smash like and we will see
you in a future video